pierre-henri bonjour et merci d'être
notre invité ce matin en direct sur arte
france alors on vient justement de
présenter ce nouveau camp nouvelle
génération camps fermés pour les
demandeurs d'asile à samos on parle de
scanners biométriques de contrôle de
déplacement des barbelés
un camp qui a des airs de prison plus de
confort mais moins de liberté tout
simplement selon vous
évoquez il faut partir de la situation
qui prévaut sur les îles grecques et
cette situation était totalement
catastrophique je connais bien les îles
grecques pour mieux être rendu à
plusieurs reprises
c'était le cas aussi je prends par
exemple
l'île de lesbos
il y avait un camp à moriat qui était
destiné à 600 personnes est en réalité
vous en aviez 7000 donc moi tout ce qui
concourt à la dignité des personnes dans
leur accueil est
évidemment une très bonne chose
maintenant il faut s'entendre sur ce que
veut dire centre fermé s'il s'est imposé
des règles de sécurité
la nuit pour les résidences est normal
et ça se passe dans la plupart des camps
y compris géré par le haut commissariat
aux réfugiés
la nuit donc rien d'extraordinaire par
contre si il s'agit
d'imposer à un certain nombre de quotas
et de faire en sorte que ceux qui ne
peuvent pas rentrer dans le centre sont
laissés à l'abandon la s'impose un
certain nombre de problèmes autrement
dit il faut une vigilance active sur ce
qui va se passer autour de ces camps
mais je crois que on peut d'abord
applaudir
l'effort de la communauté européenne
parce que ce sont des financements de la
communauté européenne qui permettent
aujourd'hui à la grèce d'avoir des
structures d'accueil
convenable ensuite oui il faut être
vigilant quant à l'exercice des libertés
mais imposer la sécurité n'est pas
véritablement d'un problème car vous
l'avez dit c'est un camp qui a financé
par l'union européenne
d'autres camps devront d'ailleurs être
construit sur plusieurs îles de la mer
egée vous parlez beaucoup de vigilance
voilà sur
sur le côté sur le fonctionnement
justement de ces camps nouvelle
génération à surveiller de près donc par
le haut commissariat de l'onu
oui oui mais le haut commissariat de
l'onu de toute façon était soucier ah
non pas la construction des corps mais
pourra rentrer dans les camps et dira
très clairement quelles sont les
conditions
le mot centre fermé et peut-être utilisé
à mauvais escient encore une fois et
s'il s'agit simplement d'assurer la
sécurité la nuit est de faire en sorte
que entre 20h et 21h mais 8 heures le
matin il n'y a pas de mouvements à
l'intérieur du camp il n'y a rien de
très choquant le véritable problème
c'est de savoir si en dehors
du nombre de places allouées les autres
demandeurs d'asile qui arriveront
seront accueillis ou seront rejetés
parce que au passage je dis que oui bien
sûr il y à moins d'arriver sur les îles
grecques qu'il y a deux ans blé d'abord
bien je vous rappelle qu'il ya eu une
pandémie qui
a limité les déplacements et puis que
d'autre part malgré les dénégations du
gouvernement
conservateur grec
les migrants sont le plus souvent
repoussés vers
la turquie et que par ailleurs la grèce
construit également
mais ça devient une habitude pour la
plupart des pays un mur
avec avec la la turquie et à renforcer
évidemment ces contrôles donc voilà sur
le camp lui-même et sur la
multiplication de ces
structures d'accueil sur les îles
grecques très sincèrement il y en avait
besoin parce que les pitons villes dans
lesquelles vivait les personnes étaient
tout simplement
indigne et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
le corps de maria a par exemple les
partis en fumée il ya quelques mois à la
suite d'un incendie songez il y avait
sept mille personnes qui vivaient là
dans des conditions absolument
dramatique donc moi je ne serai pas de
ceux qui fustigent cette
cette création mais je suis de ceux qui
regardent avec attention ce qui va s'y
passer merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir mieux à notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien président
de france terre d'asile et actuel
président de france fraternité